Pablo Escobar was the world's most
successful drug trafficker
he was also its most deadly during his
17-year reign at the top of the
Colombian cocaine Empire he ordered the
killings of thousands of people
including judges ministers of
Parliament's and even presidential
candidates at the height of its power he
was raking in over a million dollars a
day yet in the end he was forced to live
as a fugitive in the Colombian jungle
shot down on a rooftop in the city that
he ruled over his was an epic fall from
grace in this episode of biographic Swee
go deep into the South American drug
world to reveal the true life of Don
Pablo
[Music]
pablo emilio escobar Gaviria was born on
december the 1st 1949 in the small town
of renege row 45 minutes from Medellin
Colombia his father Abel was a
hard-working humble cattle farmer while
his mother her milder was a
schoolteacher Pablo the second of seven
children was raised in a middle-class
environment in a community that was
fueled by the cocaine and marijuana
trade although not everyone directly
participated in the drug business they
all had a powerful incentive in the
protection of those that did the
violence that was part and parcel of
enforcing the narcotics trade was all
around them before starting school the
family moved to end of agarró a small
village just inside of medellin so that
her elder could establish an elementary
school there Abel sold the farm and took
up a job as a neighborhood watch man
through her work at the school her
milder soon became a popular and
well-respected member of the community
at school Pablo proved himself to be
enable and quick-witted students
although tending toward the chubby side
thanks to his love of fast food he was
talented in all ball sports with a
special love for soccer many of his
teachers were involved in social causes
especially the struggle for classic
quality and they became very powerful
influences on the young Pablo by the
time he was in his early teens Pablo was
attending street rallies and
participating in such activities like
throwing rocks at the police parlez
became part of a youth culture movement
known as anodized MOU which encouraged
young people to thumb their noses at the
established order they were to do things
like disobey their parents and write
their own rules part of this
counterculture movements involved
experimentation with drugs leading the
thirteen-year-old future drug kingpin to
develop an addiction to marijuana which
would never leave him
by the age of 16 Pablo had developed
into a plump short youth standing at
just over five foot six inches in a
round face and what a slight mustache a
couple of months before reaching his
17th birthday he dropped out of school
board with the straight-laced routine
and keen to make his own way in the
world after quitting school the
enterprising pablum started up a bicycle
repair shop he would prowl the streets
since the local dump in search of
discarded bicycle parts and then used
them to fix bikes for cheap with the
money that he made from this enterprise
he purchased himself a Lambretta
motorcycle now with a means of fast
escape he began planning how to make
more money more easily than by repairing
bicycles for a pittance
according to legend Pablo's foray into
crime began with him stealing headstones
from the local cemetery sounds lasting
the names from them and then reselling
them Pablo then decided though that the
route to quick cash lay in commercial
business robbery he started by scoping
out potential targets he would then ride
to the target business on his motorbike
serve a balaclava over his head and
rushed the business with a knife or a
gun in hand demanding money and then he
got out of that all of this would happen
in about 30 seconds after a few
successful robberies Tablet recruited
his cousin to join him one would ride
the bike enactors the getaway ride a
while the other stormed into the
business bus within a few months Pablo
became bored of this and moved on to
bigger and easier things he established
a contact with a Renault car dealership
who would provide him with copies of the
keys to cars that he had just sold along
with the addresses of the buyers all the
Pablo had to do was turn up at the
address and drive the cars away in his
late teens though Pablo got caught in
the act of stealing one of these cars
ended up spending several months in la
la da da jail which was to him a very
positive life experience it was in this
jail that he learns how to move into
bigger criminal activity including
kidnapping and drug trafficking
[Music]
once back on the street Pablo and his
cousin Gustavo went right back to
stealing cars they built up a collection
of stolen engine parts which they would
sell off bit by bit the pair then took
to building race cars with Pablo
competing in local events Pablo and
Garcia weren't the only ones stealing
cars in medellin though which led to an
extension of his operation he decided to
also sell protection so the people would
pay him to ensure that their car did not
get taken
Pablo was able to provide such a service
because he had developed a reputation as
an unpredictable and violent young man
if anyone owed him money Pablo would
hire a local thug to kidnap that person
he would then ransom him for whatever
was oh dear from time to time he would
even have that person killed when the
ransom was paid simply to engender fear
in those he dealt with before long
Pablo decided to specialize in
kidnappings for their own sake along
with his cousin and future
brother-in-law he nabbed a rich
businessman by the name of Diego
echeveria this man was intensely
disliked by many of the poor workers in
Medellin who were being laid off in
droves by industrialists like him
despite the family okaying the $50,000
ransom demands Hechavarria was beaten
strangled and then dumped in a ditch
even though he had just committed a
terrible crime his choice of victim made
Pablo hugely popular among the common
folk of Medellin in a strange way they
saw the killings as Pablo striking a
blow for social equality
[Music]
so in 1971 the 22 year old Pablo began
working for Medellin based contraband
dealer Alvaro Prieto under Prieto Pablo
was doing a modest amount of drug
trafficking before long however he
decided that he wanted more of a slice
of the pie for himself he drove the
stolen Renault 4 to Ecuador and bought 5
kilograms of Peruvian cocaine paste
successfully passing through a number of
police and military checkpoints he
returned to Medellin where he processed
the cocaine he next contacted fellow
criminals the Eto'o brothers to set up a
sale to a local cocaine chief called
Fabio Restrepo the sale netted Pablo
close to a hundred thousand dollars far
surpassing anything he had previously
done and setting himself up firmly on
the path to becoming a high-end drug
dealer within two months
Fabio Restrepo had been murdered
suddenly there was a new man of the head
of the medellin cocaine operation and I
was Pablo Escobar
now importantly it has never been
conclusively proven the Pablo murdered
Restrepo but that was what everyone
involved believed the majority of people
working for Restrepo were a class
Dandy's they were pretty frightened by
Pablo and the ruthless hoodlums that he
surrounded himself with shortly after
muscling his way to the top of the
Medellin cocaine syndicate Pablo married
fifteen year old Maria Victoria Helena
Vallejo so now Pablo he was 26 years old
he had a wife he had wealth and yet
power it really seemed like the sky was
going to be the limit Vika came trade
from Panama through Colombia and into
the United States boomed in the late
1970s with most of it being trafficked
through Escobar's organization under
Pablo the cocaine industry became
Streamlight he purchased a fleet of
airplanes including a Learjet to
transport the drugs into the United
States where there was an inexhaustible
supply of willing buyers two months
after his wedding though Pablo and four
others were arrested returning from a
drug run to Ecuador Drug Enforcement
agents found 39 kilos of cocaine hidden
in the spare tire of their truck that
amount of coke would see Pablo
put away for a long long time his first
tactic in getting
the mess was to bribe the trial judge
the offer however was flatly rejected
Pablo then had his team researched the
judges background they discovered that
he had a brother who was a lawyer and
that the two men did not get on the
lawyer was contacted and offered a huge
amount to represent Pablo in the case as
suspected the judge was forced to recuse
himself due to the conflict of interest
and the new judge felt he had less
scruples about taking the payments he
accepted the bribe and Pablo and his
cohorts walked free exorbitant amounts
of money went out pouring into Colombia
with deposits in the country's four
major banks doubling between 1976 and
1980 Pablo was then able to use his
millions to take possession of every
step of his operation travelling to Peru
Bolivia and Panama and buying up all the
cultivation farms and processing plants
he was also able to buy off enforcement
agencies in every country developing a
ruthless policy which came to be known
as silver or let if officials didn't
accept his bribe they could expect to
end up dead by 1980 Pablo was at the
absolute height of his power with every
law-enforcement agency on his payroll
he was the unofficial king of Medellin
he wasn't the only cocaine impresario in
Colombia but he certainly was the most
successful
he owns multiple mansions he had racing
cars helicopters and planes and was
constantly surrounded by bodyguards and
hangers on cocaine money absolutely
transformed Marion with discos and
high-end restaurants opening up all over
the city
one of Pablo's passions was soccer and
now he was able to indulge it he paid to
have fields leveled and soldered and
lights installed so that he and his crew
could play at nighttime he also employed
professional game callers to announce
the matches as if they were an FA Cup
final in 1979 Pablo built a lavish
country estate on a 7400 acre ranch 80
miles outside of Medellin and he dubbed
it Hacienda Lost nopales he brought
exotic animals from all over the world
to populate the farm built six swimming
pools and a huge mansion that could
sleep 100 guests at the same time that
he was indulging his every materialistic
whim in private Pablo began tending to
his public image he constantly denied
that he was involved in any
illicit activity portraying a formal
likable persona and appearing humble and
polite he consciously cultivated the
image that he was a freedom fighter for
the underprivileged setting himself up
as an alternative to the establishment
he also poured millions of dollars into
social construction programs between
1980 and 1982 Pablo did more to help the
poor in Medellin than the Colombian
government had ever done one of his most
popular initiatives was a housing
project that was called barrio Pablo
Escobar where houses were built and
given to families who had previously
been sheltering in shacks at the city
dump this and a host of other projects
easily made him the most popular citizen
in Medellin in private
Pablo conducted himself in an
understated manner he spoke softly and
was generally relaxed and casual with
the people around him he was also hugely
Self Indulgence with food with drink and
with women and he considered himself a
law unto himself as an example of this
on one occasion when an employee was
found to have stolen from him Pablo had
him brought before him bound hand and
foot and then kicked him into the
smoogle making everyone watch as the man
drowned
[Music]
with his popularity among the masses
firmly established and his dominance
over his empire assured the next logical
step for Pablo was politics his path to
legitimate office began in 1978 when he
was elected as a substitute city
councilor in Medellin in 1980 he gave
his personal and financial support of
the formation of a new national
political movement the new Liberal Party
then in 1982 he ran formed and was
elected to Congress all that as a
substitute who attended when the primary
delegate for Medellin was unavailable a
major perk of being elected to Congress
was that now Pablo had judicial immunity
meaning that he could not be convicted
for any crime under Colombian law the
position also afforded him a diplomatic
visa which he made use of to regularly
take his family on trips to the United
States on one of these trips he
purchased an 8 million dollar mansion in
Miami Beach Florida so Pablo now had
political legitimacy to go with his
massive wealth and the next acquisition
he made was a personal army one of
friends of the family was kidnapped by
m-19 guerrillas he created a private
militia to hunt down these rebels
Pablo's army was known as death to
kidnappers so Pablo's wider exposure as
a result of this political office well
it was the beginning of his downfall in
Medellin Pablo he was viewed as this
Robin Hood figure but when he tried to
gain the favor of polite Colombian
society he was not welcomed they viewed
him as what he really was a ruthless
cocaine king with absolutely no scruples
when he turns up to take his seat in
Congress as an alternate for the first
time on August the 16th 1983 with a bevy
of bodyguards in tow he was first denied
entry for not wearing a tie he quickly
got hold of one and swept into the packs
chamber he slumped down in his allocated
seat and began nervously to bite his
fingernails immediately the chamber
president stood and demanded that all
bodyguards be removed from the chamber
Pablo nodded and his thugs left the room
within minutes justice minister
Rodriguez Lara was on his feet defending
a claim of corruption that had been
brought against him Lara pointed his
finger at Pablo and stated we have a
congressman who was born in a very poor
area himself very very poor and
afterwards through astute business deals
in bicycles and other things appears
with a gigantic fortune with nine planes
three hangars at the medina airport and
creates the movement death to kidnappers
while on the other hand mounts
charitable organizations with which he
tries to bribe a needy and unprotected
people and there are investigations
going in the United States of which I
cannot inform you here tonight in the
house on the criminal conduct of Pablo
Escobar now Pablo said nothing in the
house but when he left he was besieged
by reporters breaking free he stormed
off through his lawyer he informs Lara
that if he did not present evidence of
his claims within 24 hours he would face
legal action
Lara willingly obliged and in the coming
days the newspapers were filled with all
sorts of revelations about Pablo's
criminal activity
[Music]
Pablo was now persona non grata in
political circles he was kicked out of
the new Liberal Party and the u.s.
embassy revoked his diplomatic visa the
Catholic Church also renounced their
support of him the government even
seized 85 of the exotic animals on
Pablo's ranch claiming that they entered
the country illegally
Pablo's political career was now in
ruins even worse for tabloid the
Colombian government lara's urgings was
fast tracking an extradition treaty with
the US that would see him tried in
America for selling cocaine in that
country in May of 1984 justice minister
lara was shot seven times while riding
in his chauffeur-driven limousine but
Pablo had powerful enemies US President
Ronald Reagan had announced a major
crackdown on the cocaine trade with the
death of Lara the Colombian government
were willing to cooperate with American
authorities to go after narco kingpins
and Pablo he was the biggest of them all
the killing of Lara also turns much of
the Colombian population against public
by this act he had declared war on the
state for Pablo the heat was too much to
bear and he skipped the country taking a
helicopter to Panama City yes despite
being offered asylum in Panama just the
year before Pablo and his cronies were
not welcomed by the authority after just
a few weeks in exile Pablo he was
desperate to get back home he made
overtures to the Colombian government
drafting a proposal whereby he would go
straight and use this massive influence
to rid Colombia of drug trafficking
provided that he could retain his
possessions in Medellin and that he
would be exempt from arrest or
extradition to the United States this
offer though it was roundly rejected
when the Panamanian army raided one of
the labs that he had situated on the
Colombian border he fled Panama for
Nicaragua
meanwhile he was hearing that his
absence from Colombia was undermining
his control of the Medellin Cartel
the kidnapping of his 73 year-old father
while that was a step too far
Pablo ordered a killing frenzy
throughout Medellin dozens of suspected
kidnappers they were just gunned down
finally they gave in and Pablo's old man
was released with no ransom ever being
paid
[Music]
in the midst of the carnage over his
father's kidnapping Pablo returned to
Colombia he was now determined to take
on the state with everything that he had
around Medellin he was untouchable
having bought off every official this
allowed him although being the most
wanted man in the country to move around
the town freely
Pablo's vengeful focus during the
mid-80s was squarely centered on the
judiciary especially judges who
supported the extradition treaty with
the US during this time more than 30
judges were shot dead then in November
of 1985 the guerrilla group m-19 having
been paid a million dollars by Pablo
stormed the palace of justice and tells
the entire Supreme Court hostage they
demanded that the government renounce
the extradition treaty in the resulting
siege 11 of the 24 justices along with
40 of the rebels were killed by the
beginning of 1988 killings were being
reported on an almost daily basis
martial law was declared to earn the
state from toppling on August the 18th
1989 Pablo's kill squads gunned down
both the front-running presidential
candidates Luis Galen and a state police
chief in the following four months the
Colombian government apprehended and
sent more than 20 suspected drug
traffickers to the United States to
stand trial a national police unit was
stationed to Medellin specifically to
hunt down
Pablo within the first month thirty of
the 200 men stationed there had been
killed
Pablo was evading his government's and
inflicting enormous casualties but he
was a man constantly on the run he
always stayed a step ahead of his
pursuers that he was growing tired of
the constant relocations that were
needed eventually he was driven to
negotiate Pablo agreed to put an end to
all the violence to stop all criminal
activity and hand himself in in exchange
he demanded preferential treatment in a
prison of his choosing and a reduced
settlement the government had already
revoked the extradition treaty to the US
with its 1991 constitution so he didn't
have to worry about being sent to
America and with all of that Pablo was
duly arrested and duly tried he began
his sentence at Locati
our prison in June of 1991 this well it
was like no other prison on earth it
featured a football pitch to kuzey and a
bar all of the prison guards were
Pablo's employees the prison cells were
more like hotel suites and the food that
Pablo and his fellow inmates ate was
prepared by chefs who were brought in
from the finest restaurants but after a
few months accounts began to reach
official channels that Pablo was
continuing to pursue his criminal
activities from the prison this was a
violation of the surrender agreements
and moves were put in place to seize him
and move him to a regular prison
Pablo's connections enabled him to get a
wind of the plan and he escaped before
authorities could get to him
that for babbler is back on but now the
US and Colombian authorities were joined
by a vigilante group known as los pepes
which stood for people persecuted by
Pablo Escobar los peppers carried out a
ruthless campaign killing as many as 300
people who were connected to Pablo and
his organization following his escape
Pablo was constantly on the run most of
his closest associates were dead and his
organization was totally falling apart
he was spending nights sleeping in the
jungle afraid to speak on the radio or
even to answer the phone
finally they faked caught up with Pablo
Escobar on December the 2nd 1993 members
of the Colombian search bloc team had
tracked him down to her house in Los
Olivos in Medellin via radio intercepts
the search bloc team smashed through the
heavy steel door with a sledgehammer
whereupon six of them rushed into the
house it was then the shooting started
with Pablo in the house was his most
loyal bodyguard known as Limon they both
bolted from the front room and made
their way up into the roof the six
search bloc members along with others
outside port a massive barrage of
gunfire at their targets Lymon was hit
several times in the back and toppled to
the ground below then Pablo went down he
was struck several times in the leg and
torso but the fatal shot penetrated his
skull on confirming his target the
leader of the operation spoke excitedly
into his radio viva la Colombia we have
just killed Pablo Escobar but that day
Babloo had always told his family that
if cornered he would commit suicide by
placing a bullet in his skull many
people believe that he did so once more
escaping the clutches of the Colombian
authorities so I really hope you enjoyed
that episode of biographic if you did
there's a couple of things you could do
right now one is hit that like button
below also if you want more stuff like
this we put out brand new videos every
Monday and every Thursday so hit that
subscribe button below and subscribe
button doesn't do what it used to on
YouTube if you actually want to get a
notification about these videos please
do hit that Bell button next to the
subscribe button and that'll send you a
notification every time every Monday and
Thursday won't put out a new video also
if you want to watch something else
right now stuff from the archive over
there on the right and as always thank
you for watching
[Music]
you